part-2 I in fact don't even need to
touch any equations at all if I
understand this answer correctly when
I'm solving for x equals negative 30
where is that on the graph are you
getting sick of me talking about where
it is on the graph yet are you seeing
how important graphs are in this we know
where 30 is right it is
where's negative 30 it's gonna be just
down below right on the opposite side so
if this is where negative 30 is roughly
then the first time that the particle
what is this thing it's a particle it's
gonna be at negative 30 all the way over
here right do you see that so have a
look at where that is on the graph it's
roughly there now I said you shouldn't
need any equations to get this answer
right have a look how are you going to
work out where that is on the basis of
this piece of information
then again pull plus 12 what's going on
here see this little distance right the
0.965 you can clearly see it's mirrored
in this distance here right there is all
this symmetry around simple harmonic
motion which is why we like it so much
it's really nice to work with so if
those distances are the same then to get
to this nuance how x equals negative 30
all right x equals negative 30 when the
time is equal to that that time
12 seconds forward does that make sense
so I can just write 12 plus 12 on PI
sign and I can say that from the graph
because I have a good graph and actually
visually argues that for me of course
you could go through the whole process
and work this out by the equations but I
think this is rather more efficient and
elegant as well okay before I move on to
the last part Part C does anyone have
any questions on this part cuz it's
weird it's confusing and you needed some
time on it okay again just like before
for Part C I'm going to leave that
equation there and I'm going to start
you off on it and get you solving it
before I then show you myself
okay so Part C says find the first two
times its speed is half its max
speed its speed is half its maximum
speed now I have a velocity equation
here it's not a speed equation okay but
I'm going to use the velocity equation
and just think about it carefully with
my pluses and minuses that's the
difference between velocity and speed
right what is the maximum speed you can
just read it off right it's 10 pi right
so I'm going to get on my way to finding
the solution to this by saying when is
this which is the velocity when is this
equal to half of that which is which is
what was the maximum speed again 10 pi
so half of that will be 5 pi okay now
again you have to be careful because the
solution to this equation is not the
answer to our question let me say that
again the solution to this equation is
not just going to be the answer to our
question because there's more to it than
that right this only solves for in the
velocity is equal to that but the
velocity could be going in the opposite
direction and it would still be okay
right and we want the first two times so
they're clearly talking about when it's
changed direction that's going the other
way okay so I'm gonna let that sit there
as a start you can solve for time but
they don't want you to think about how
do you use that to then work out well
what about the other time when you're go
in the opposite direction
have a shot let me so these don't know I
know if you think you in the right
direction or absolutely confused and
don't know now I wrote this equation out
okay without this graph to help me it
just so happens that that is fine but
I'm always gonna encourage you to have
the graph there you'll see when we're
having a look at the second the second
time that this becomes even more
important in order to interpret what's
going on but if you haven't already
please go ahead and draw your time
velocity graph because they'll be very
very handy right now they've said when
is it the first time that it's half its
maximum speed so 10 pi up here this is
the velocity right that's a spot at
which sorry that's a time at which it is
at its maximum speed when is the next
time and this is a different question
what we're being asked but I just want
to get a sense of the graph what is the
next time that we hit the maximum speed
this is time zero up here when's the
next time
the next times gonna be down here isn't
it at this point here the velocity is
negative 10 pi but that means that this
speed is 10 PI right does that make
sense so you're hitting the maximum
speed here as well they're just going in
that direction rather than that
direction so I don't want to solve when
is it equal to five pi what am I
actually looking for whoops wrong color
here's five pi in here because it's you
know half so that's why it's half the
amplitude so I'm expecting an answer
like here right thereabouts so when I go
ahead and I solve this equation I divide
through I get cos of Pi on 12t equals
1/2 because it's it's half of the
maximum speed at this point this is 1/2
and you're like oh I have exact values
for this right so you can say PI on 12 T
should be equal to what's the first
answer you're expecting for off think
this is going to be PI on 3 right thank
you very much 60 degrees okay but we're
in radians of course so the time that
goes along with that particular value is
going to be 4 seconds right now let's
just do a quick sense check before we
think about this answer any further does
that look like 4 seconds to you is your
graph reasonable is my graph reasonable
enough again I'm going to have a look
over here halfway just to get a smaller
sense of the scale that's 12 yeah that
looks like I can go even further
actually that's 6 right there because
you go half again that looks pretty good
to me are you happy with that
so I've done a very quick sense check to
confirm now I made sort of a big deal
over here about how when you go from
trigonometric functions to universe
trigonometric functions you go from many
many solutions to just one ok and here I
never wrote down cos inverse but I have
just one solution
why don't I bother looking for any more
because I could I could write like what
would the next one be 5 PI on 35.3 why
don't I bother writing that hmm yeah I
would the first two times write the
first two times now the next time I'm at
5 PI you can see from the graph is way
over here
okay and that's going to be irrelevant -
that's way too late I want the first two
times it's all gonna be on this end of
the graph okay so now I can say I've got
another color Kia the next time is not
going to be when it's back to 5 PI the
velocity it'll be when it's at negative
5 PI like so ok now you could reach for
your equations in fact I will do that
just in a second to confirm it but do
you really need your equations have a
look at the graph look can you see just
like I did over there can you see the
symmetry here one last color see this
distance here or that time rather it's a
time distance on the graph that time is
how far how long from 4 to 6 it's 2
seconds right and you can see from the
shape of the graph that that's the same
2 seconds that you're going to see there
does that make sense
so what answer are you anticipating 8
seconds that's what I'm anticipating how
can I confirm that I have equations
right so I'm gonna go I've solved this
this is done I'm gonna go cars fine I'm
12 T or I need the other stuff don't
know 10 pi equals negative 5 PI I'm
gonna go ahead and solve nerdy done yeah
now this again also has an exact value
do you know it well do you know well
think of it because curve does it's
gonna be it's 2 pi + 3 isn't it 120
degrees - fine
on 3 you could use your calculator to
double-check this if you want there's PI
on 12
but you've already can see like this is
double what I had before so that's why
sure enough you get your 8 seconds ok so
I asked a few of you before you like
coach through the equations you've got
an answer right but MIT very few of you
could say yes I absolutely can conclude
yes I'm confident in the center but I
think the graph is going to be your best
thing to lean on they're not just say
yes I can convince someone else but I
can say yeah I'm happy in this example
on text I can move on now okay so
questions will not usually take that
long this is still really early on it
you say any be familiar with the kind of
language that they use and how to use
the graph they've never asked me to
graph at any
point but hopefully I've convinced you
by the way I've done the question how
instrumental and useful the graph is
it's just beneficial just do it it takes
so quick even if you just draw a rough
one okay